Le gel Fixafort résiste à tous les éléments...
Air, feu, eau et terre, très bien.
Bien joué Louisa.
Gérard vous avez quoi ?
Alors moi pour cette campagne j'ai pensé à une pub dans laquelle on aurait un adolescent traversant la rue, qui se fait percuter par un camion.
Là, l'adolescent est indemne, le camion est complètement détruit... Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il a percuté la coupe de cheveux de l'adolescent.
Gel Fixafort.
Ok, pas mal du tout, je note.
C'est... C'est efficace.
Didier vous avez quoi?
C'est à vous Didier.
C'est à vous Didier, on vous écoute.
Euh... Oui...
Je... Je...
Je... Je suis parti du principe que les consommateurs de gel...
Sont... Majoritairement...
Des...
Des adolescents.
Et ce que font généralement les adolescents...
C'est qu'ils...
Bah ils jouent aux jeux vidéos.
Ils écoutent beaucoup de musique.
Et donc comme ils écoutent beaucoup de musique... Bah...
Ils sont fans de leurs chanteurs.
Tout à fait.
Et donc, en prenant en considération tous ces éléments,
qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir dans notre campagne de pub ?
Leur chanteur préféré ?
Qui serait coiffé avec du gel Fixafort.
Exactement.
C'est ça, c'était l'idée que j'avais.
Ok, bah très bonne idée Didier.
Simple, efficace, exactement ce qu'il nous faut pour la campagne.
Super.
Bon bah on est bon pour ce brief.
Alors ensuite on a quoi?
Penser à la forme de la nouvelle bouteille de gel douche Sonex.
Didier vous avez l'air en forme, on va commencer par vous.
Euh... Alors, quelles sont les formes de savon qui existent sur le marché ?
Les bouteilles de gel douche transparentes ?
Oui...
Les blocs de savon traditionnels.
C'est ça, et ?
C'est tout.
Et c'est tout.
Et donc comment est-ce qu'on pourrait apporter quelque chose de nouveau ?
Une bouteille de gel douche en forme de bloc de savon traditionnel.
Bingo.
Le mix des deux.
Mais c'est super ça comme idée Didier.
Les autres prenez exemple sur Didier.
Bah j'avais justement...
Non Gérard je pense que là on aura pas mieux que ce brief-la, donc vous fatiguez pas.
Alors, utilitaire Renolt Habile.
Gérard on vous écoute.
Non, Didier ce sera plus simple.
Alors pour ça j'ai pensé à un petit truc donc je suis pas peu fier.
Vous allez voir. Qui dit véhicule utilitaire, dit ?
Attendez !
Didier se joue de nous depuis le début.
Qu'est-ce que vous racontez Gérard ?
C'est nous qui faisons tout le boulot.
Aucune des idées ne vient de lui.
Didier, est-ce qu'il dit la vérité ?
J'ai raison, n'est-ce pas ?
Montre-nous ton travail.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ton petit ordinateur là ?
Alors ?
C'est bien ce que je pensais.
Que dalle.
Dans ce cas...
Je vais être grand prince.
Je vais me permettre de te montrer la porte.
Bye Didier.
A la revoyure.
Alors là c'est très intéressant ce qu'il se passe.
Regardez-bien Gérard.
Et dites-moi, qu'est-ce que vous ressentez chez lui ?
Une sorte de...
Nervosité.
Ouais...
Une sorte de frustration.
Presque.
La jalousie.
De la jalousie.
Pas du tout.
Et pourquoi ça ?
Parce qu'il a de moins bonnes idées que nous.
C'est ça...
Parce que c'est un looser comme on a rarement vu.
Ça c'est faux.
Et on devrait le licencier.
Carrément ?
Pour faute grave, comme ça il aurait pas d'indemnités.
Vous savez quoi ? Je le vire.
Vous êtes viré Gérard.
On devrait mettre feu à sa maison pendant qu'on y est.
Vous êtes une merde Gérard.
Ah c'est une merde.